quelques jours après l'iran c'est donc
la corée du nord qui joue avec les nerfs
de la communauté internationale le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu se réunit
en ce moment même pour décider d'une
réponse appropriée au nouvel essai
nucléaire réalisé aujourd'hui par la
corée du nord
c'est le deuxième essai depuis octobre
2006 barack obama a estimé que les
activités nucléaires de ce pays
représentait une grave menace pour la
paix huet a un court laps de temps le
sismographe s'affole un tremblement de
terre est aussitôt c'est scientifique
sud-coréen
le phénomène est fréquent dans la région
mais l'explication est ailleurs
c'est ce présentateur de la télévision
nord-coréenne qu'il annonce son pays
vient de procéder à un essai nucléaire
souterrain le deuxième depuis 2006 un
essai réussi quelques heures plus tard
nouveau pied de nez la corée du nord
tirent trois missiles à courte portée le
japon voisin cibles potentielles
syndicale initie la corée du nord a
procédé à un essai nucléaire
ce serait une violation évidente des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité nous
ne pouvons l'accepter même émotion en
corée du sud où des manifestants brûlent
des portraits du président kim jong il
la détente avec le peu accommodant
frères du nord semble bien loin pourquoi
le dictateur kim jong-il à la santé
chancelante se livre-t-il à une telle
provocation
difficile de savoir ce qui se trame dans
ce pays sans doute le plus fermé au
monde le message en tout cas ne plaît
guère à barack obama
il menace la corée du nord de nouvelles
sanctions et menaces et les armements is
it n'apporteront ni la sécurité ni le
respect à la corée du nord
nous allons travailler avec nos amis et
nos alliés pour nous opposer un tel
comportement
la chine alliée traditionnelle de la
corée du nord a elle aussi condamné
l'essai nucléaire mais il n'est pas sûr
qu'elle vote de nouvelles sanctions ce
soir au conseil de sécurité des nations
unies